bienvenidos de nuevo vamos a hacer otro
problema de tensión y este es
ligeramente más difícil que el anterior
sólo porque tenemos que hacer uso de
herramientas de álgebra un poco más
sofisticadas pero no no no es más
complicado quizás sea bueno que le sigas
bien la pista a este problema porque
probablemente verás esto en un examen un
ejercicio similar así que vamos a
calcular la tensión en estos dos cables
digamos que este cable tiene una
atención de 1 y 1 y este cable tiene una
atención de 2 muy bien entonces lo que
podríamos hacer de inmediato es analizar
qué pasa con este cable digamos que es
vertical ok
y veamos este punto de aquí que estoy
marcando con morado porque éste tiene
una bueno está haciendo hay una fuerza
de gravedad que se ejerce debido al peso
de esta masa verdad y trivialmente uno
sabe que si este punto es estacionario
es decir no se mueve entonces la fuerza
de gravedad que va hacia abajo de 10
minutos
debe compensarse con una fuerza vertical
que le imprime en este cable de la misma
magnitud que en este caso son 10 newtons
verdad entonces en este caso este cable
tiene una una tensión de 10 minutos y va
hacia arriba ok ese fue el punto fácil
ahora veamos qué ocurre con este punto
de aquí arriba ok
este punto también es estacionario es
estacionario y no se mueve quiere decir
que las fuerzas o todas las componentes
verticales deben anularse de la misma
forma que todas las componentes
horizontales muy bien entonces lo que
vamos a tener que hacer es descomponer
estas dos fuerzas t1 y t2 en sus
componentes horizontales y verticales
para para ver que en efecto se cancelen
y así poder determinar cuál es la
magnitud de cada una de estas fuerzas de
tensión muy bien entonces
primero veamos que esta fuerza t 1 la
podemos descomponer en dos fuerzas una
que es horizontal y otra que es vertical
muy bien y otra que es vertical y estas
son perpendiculares entonces rápidamente
podemos deducir de propiedades de
geometría elemental que como ésta este
techo digamos que está en rojo es
paralelo a este a esta componente
entonces como la línea amarilla es una
transversal y son paralelas entonces
este ángulo de aquí también son 30
grados muy bien y esto nos sirve mucho
para poder determinar cuál es la
magnitud de la componente horizontal
recordemos por uno puede utilizar el
soca tohá
como sea que te acuerdes pero puedes
recordar que entonces esta componente
horizontal mide o tiene una magnitud de
1 desde la magnitud de 1 por el coseno
de 30 grados muy bien y ahora veamos que
esta magnitud horizontal solo puede
cancelarse con esta otra magnitud
horizontal verdad pero que va hacia la
izquierda ahora de la misma forma se
como este ángulo es de 60 grados este
ángulo de aquí será de 60 grados y
entonces esta componente horizontal de
forma análoga tiene una magnitud de
magnitud de 2 por el coseno de 60 grados
es la esto es la magnitud de esta
componente horizontal
dt 2 muy bien entonces lo que sabemos es
que esta suma o más bien este
esta componente debe ser igual o más
bien la magnitud de la componente
horizontal de t 2 debe ser igual que la
magnitud de la componente horizontal de
t 1 verdad para que así se cancelen ya
que van en direcciones contrarias
entonces esto me está diciendo que la
magnitud de t 1 por el coseno de 30
grados debe ser igual a la magnitud de t
por el coseno de 60 grados muy bien y si
esto es bueno podemos recordar que el
coseno de 30 grados esto de aquí es raíz
de 3 sobre 2 y el coseno de 60 grados es
un medio ok si no te acuerdas te
recomiendo que revises los vídeos de
funciones trigonométricas y por ejemplo
de los triángulos 30 60 90 ok entonces
si nosotros tenemos esto que cómo lo
podemos reescribir tenemos raíz de 3
sobre 2 por la norma de tf1 y vamos a
pasar esta cantidad del lado izquierdo
restando entonces tendríamos menos un
medio de la norma de t2
y esto debe ser igual a 0 ya me estoy
saltando varios pasos digamos
algebraicos pero todo esto está muy
sencillo hasta este momento espero no te
esté confundiendo ahora como no queremos
que aparezcan estos dos dividiendo
podemos multiplicar por dos de ambos
lados y qué es lo que nos queda nos
queda raíz de tres por la norma de t uno
menos
- la norma de t2 y esto tiene que ser
igual a 0 y déjenme enmarcar esta
ecuación porque tengo la sospecha de que
nos va a ser muy útil en unos minutos
aunque ya entonces acuérdense muy bien
de esta ecuación ahora como decía
podríamos descomponer estas fuerzas
también bueno más bien en su parte
horizontal y en su parte vertical aquí
faltó poner la parte vertical
ahí está ok entonces si nos damos cuenta
ahora la suma de las tensiones o de las
componentes verticales de cada una de
estas tensiones debe ser igual a 10
minutos porque estas son las únicas
fuerzas verticales que tenemos en este
diagrama además de la fuerza de gravedad
que va hacia abajo y que es de 10
minutos como este punto está en reposo
no se mueve entonces deben ser iguales
esta suma de estas dos tensiones a 10
minutos es verdad entonces qué es lo que
vamos a tener que la componente vertical
que en este caso sería vamos a ponerlo
aquí la componente vertical es la norma
de tf1
por el seno de 30 grados esta es la
primera componente vertical si le
sumamos
a componente o la magnitud de la
componente vertical de t 2 que eso sería
la magnitud de 2 por el seno de 60
grados esto debe igualar la fuerza de
gravedad que va hacia abajo que es de 10
newtons esto debe ser igual
10 newtons muy bien entonces nuevamente
el seno de 30 grados fácilmente uno
tiene que recordar que desde un medio ok
y el seno de 60 grados es de raíz de 3
sobre 2 muy bien entonces lo que tenemos
finalmente es un medio de la norma de
tf1
más la raíz de 3 sobre 2 de la norma dt
2 y esto debe ser igual a 10 newtons a
10 minutos igual nuevamente podemos
multiplicar por 2 de ambos lados y lo
que obtenemos es que la norma de t 1 más
la raíz de 3 por la norma de t 2
es igual y como multiplicamos por dos de
ambos lados es igual a 20 newtons y ya
tenemos entonces dos ecuaciones digamos
algebraicas con dos incógnitas entonces
podemos tratar de resolverlo déjenme
copiar esta misma acá abajo entonces
tendríamos raíz de 3 norma de t 1 verdad
estoy copiando esta ecuación menos la
norma de t 2 y esto debe ser igual a 0
verdad entonces qué podemos hacer
podemos multiplicar esta primera
ecuación x raíz de 3 ok vamos a bajar
tantito
podemos multiplicar la primera actuación
por raíz de 3 y qué es lo que vamos a
obtener tendremos raíz de 3 por la norma
de tf1 que multiplicamos está por raíz
de tres
a raíz de 3 x raíz de 3 sería 3 norma de
t 2
ok y esto debe ser igual a 20 raíz de 3
newtons ok entonces ahora lo que podemos
hacer yo sé que a lo mejor son pasos
medio medio extraños pero lo que podemos
hacer ahora es restar a esta ecuación
restarle esta de abajo entonces estos
términos se van a cancelar y que me
queda nos queda menos y ponerlo con el
mismo color que llevaba tendríamos menos
norma dt 2 ok y luego restamos 3 norma
dt 2 y esto me debe dar menos menos 20
raíz de 3 newtons ok aquí lo que tenemos
en total son menos 4 verdad menos 1 y
menos 3 son menos 4 norma dt 2
y esto es menos 20 menos 20 raíz de 3
newtons y entonces para despejar norma
de t 2 simplemente pasamos dividiendo
entre 4 y nos queda que la norma de t 2
es igual a 5 raíz de 3 newtons y ya
tenemos la magnitud de la atención de la
segunda cuerda ahora simplemente
recordemos que
la suma donde teníamos esa ecuación
digamos aquí está la verdad es esta
no más bien vamos a utilizar esta
ecuación tendremos que la raíz de 3 raíz
de 3 por la norma de tf1 ok
perdón más bien sería menos la norma de
t2 que en este caso dijimos que era 5
raíz de 3 newtons debe ser igual a 0
quiere decir que la norma o más bien
raíz de 3 por la norma de tf1 debe ser
igual a 5 raíz de 35 raíz de 3 minutos y
si dividimos entre raíz de 3 obtenemos
simplemente que la norma de tf1 es igual
a 5 newtons muy bien entonces tenemos ya
aquí este resultado y ya tenemos cuál es
la magnitud de cada una de estas
tensiones la primera es de 5 newtons y
por supuesto va en esta dirección y la
norma de bueno t 2 es una fuerza de 5
raíz de 3 newtons que va en esta
dirección muy bien entonces t 2 o la
atención de la segunda cuerda tiene la
mayor fuerza por qué
bueno esto lo puede tiene sentido porque
es más pronunciada verdad tiene un
ángulo más grande si lo ves es digamos
su tensión combinada de t2 y de teu no
serían más que 10 y tiene sentido porque
parte de esas tensiones se utilizan en
jalarse mutuamente de forma horizontal
entonces espero que te haya gustado este
vídeo y nos vemos en el próximo